the next question is how to do more
confident around so you know I think
this is sometimes overdone I think that
the essence is the leaf belief in your
passion belief in your product belief in
your customers belief in your people and
in a confidence the other thing that's
really important is optimism you know
again people just tend to gravitate to
people like this guy because they've got
eternal optimism belief centre purpose
and and it does create a volunteer army
where people come together behind a
mission now we'll talk about I think
it's really good to share some
vulnerabilities because you can't be
always on all the time and sometimes you
have bad day so it's kind of how do you
pick yourself up and I think you go back
to your team your mentors sometimes your
customers and actually share those
vulnerabilities just a little human
sometimes we went bad days and you find
when you share a few vulnerabilities and
you haven't got all the answers people
really stand up and become true
champions and give you inspiration to
carry up yeah hard for me to argue with
believe i'm a fan obviously I I think
what I would add to that is just knowing
that you can you can help uh when I
first started working with brands
example Microsoft was on my first
clients I thought my croissant Wow why
would Microsoft want to talk to me how
can I help Microsoft huge company they
have all this money why would I even
helped them and so that really lowered
my confidence and then I realized by
talking to them that oh these guys need
my help and so I just made me way more
confident in being able to going so
knowing that what you have can make them
better make their lives better um I feel
just helps me be a lot more confidence
not like a fake confidence not me like
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna be amazing and I'm
gonna suck you could do it Evan you
could do it right it's not that it's
just knowing in my heart that I can
actually provide value to these people
that I'm not selling them on I'm just
trying to help them that gives me the
confidence to go and do what I do yeah
you know all of it you can go and get
life coaches you can go on YouTube watch
those videos but um the best thing to do
is just practice if there's anything in
life you know like as a teenager I
didn't like walking into big groups of
people I could have completely melted
away and kind of run a mile but the more
you do it the more you get used to it
and feel lovely you shouldn't fear
anything I Evans City armored CEO and
stuff I land but I'm just a normal guy
are people like me great CEOs I know
they never forget where they came from
and they're very approachable they love
talking to customers you know then
absolutely the essence are just normal
people you want to go for a beer with so
when you think about that you know that
they're okay guys so anybody out there
is approachable if you've got something
special a great idea you've got a great
product you kind of got a responsibility
to share that with the world